und im tagesgespräch begrüße ich
katharina dröge volkswirtin und
wirtschaftspolitische sprecherin der
grünen im deutschen bundestag guten tag
vor drücke guten magen was erwarten sie
denn von diesem jahr etwas anderen davos
2021 was kann was muss dieses forum der
pandemie mit all ihren verwerfungen
entgegensetzen
also dieses weltwirtschaftsforum in
davos ist ja ein ort wo sich staatschefs
und konzernchefs austauschen über die
frage kann es so weitergehen wie bisher
oder müssen etwas anders machen und ich
glaube die pandemie hat uns sehr
deutlich gezeigt dass auch
wirtschaftspolitisch wir nicht einfach
mit dem weiter so wie bisher klar kommen
werden
die panini hat uns gezeigt dass das was
an problemen eh schon auf der welt
bestand zum beispiel die hohe soziale
ungleichheit sich noch einmal verschärft
hat das heißt die armen werden ärmer die
reichen werden reicher
da gegenzusteuern eine welt
wirtschaftspolitik zu machen die auf
gerechtigkeit insbesondere für den
globalen süden setzt das wäre jetzt ein
wichtiges zeichen dass von da wo es
ausgehen könnte und müsste den ton hat
ja kürzlich der gründer des
weltwirtschaftsforums klaus schwab
gesetz und gesagt 2021 böte die chance
den kapitalismus neu zu denken also nach
der pandemie anders zu wirtschaften als
vor corinna gibt es diese chance
wirklich oder machen gewinnorientierte
unternehmen nach der pandemie nicht
genauso weiter wie vorher
die gefahr ist groß dass
gewinnorientierte unternehmen einfach so
weitermachen wie vorher wir als
weltgemeinschaft können und dürfen uns
das aber nicht leisten denn nach der
korona pandemie kommt die nächste noch
größere krise und dass es die klimakrise
und wir sind jetzt im entscheidenden
jahrzehnt als weltgemeinschaft um auch
umzusteuern um umzusteigen auf eine
wirtschaftsweise die die endlichkeit des
planeten watt die auf eine klimaneutrale
technologie setzt und das müssen wir
jetzt alle gemeinsam schaffen als
industrieländer insbesondere haben wir
die aufgabe da voran zu gehen und zu
zeigen wie es geht aber wir müssen auch
den globalen süden dabei unterstützen
dass er nicht denselben umwelt
den umweg geht stehen wir die letzten
jahrzehnte gegangen sind und auch da in
eine grüne wirtschaft investieren
was kann denn ein land wie deutschland
tun um die korona bedingten verwerfungen
vor allem die nachteile die korona dem
süden der hemisphäre der erde gebracht
hat abzufedern
also auf der einen seite geht es um eine
faire handelspolitik die endlich den
ländern des globalen südens affäre
wirtschaftliche chancen gibt wir machen
handelsverträge die sehr einseitig zu
unseren gunsten ausgerichtet sind die
länder des globalen südens in
abhängigkeiten bringen dass sie
weiterhin die exporteure von rohstoffen
sind aber die gesamte verarbeitende
industrie hier bei uns stattfindet das
zu ändern da endlich auf faire
handelsverträge zu setzen würde
wirtschaftliche chancen und damit auch
mehr wohlstand in den ländern des
globalen südens bringen und das zweite
ist auch in den wirtschaftsbeziehungen
den klimaschutz in den mittelpunkt zu
stellen wir beispielsweise haben uns den
wahnsinnigen luxus geleistet wertvolle
ressourcen die in unserem gütern sind
einfach wegzuwerfen zu verbrennen müll
ist das stichwort mindestens
designfehler wir brauchen eine
kreislaufwirtschaft die auf recycling
setzt und da jetzt überall auf der welt
mit anzufangen das auch in den ländern
des globalen südens zu fördern das wäre
eine große wirtschaftliche und
klimapolitische chance dass werden
impulse die auch von einer kanzlerin
merkel ausgehen müssten
und genau das hat die hilfsorganisation
oxfam gestern auch gefordert nämlich die
wirtschaft zu demokratisieren
unternehmen sollten ja
gemeinwohlorientiert reguliert werden
heißt es da fairen handelspraktiken wie
sie gerade gesagt haben eingehalten
werden aber wenn man sieht wie schwer
sich allein deutschland mit dem
lieferketten gesetzt dass noch immer
kein gesetz ist scheint das doch
politisch alles nur schwer oder kaum
durchsetzbar es ist ein riesenfehler
dass insbesondere angela merkel aber
auch wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
beim wird beim lieferketten gesetz so
auf der bremse stehen während
entwicklungsminister müller aber auch
arbeitsminister haider gesagt haben wir
brauchen dieses gesetz endlich wir
fordern angela merkel darauf zu ihrem
wort zu stehen das ist im
koalitionsvertrag verankert und wir
können als deutschland unsere
unternehmen in die verantwortung nehmen
wir müssen sie in die verantwortung
dafür nehmen dass sie überall auf der
welt wo sie produzieren auch
mindeststandards für menschenrechte für
den umweltschutz einhalten
dass es am ende überhaupt kein nachteil
für die unternehmen sondern eine vorteil
weil ich bin davon überzeugt
auch die konsumenten werden das nicht
mehr akzeptieren solche produkte zu
kaufen
das heißt wenn ihre partei die grünen
nach der nächsten bundestagswahl teil
der koalition sein sollten wäre dieses
lieferketten gesetz bald realität
selbstverständlich würden wir in jedem
fall bei einer koalition darauf drängen
dass es ein wirksames lieferketten
gesetz gibt und ich bin auch überzeugt
davon dass wir das durchsetzen können
und setzen ja in deutschland in europa
auf der ganzen welt viele große
hoffnungen auf den neuen us präsidenten
joe biden
glauben sie dass er die amerikanische
handelspolitik nach vier jahren des
protektionismus des unilateralismus
wirklich wieder stärker nach ja globaler
zusammenarbeit ausrichten wird
mit blick auf die präsidentschaft von
joe biden lohnt sich glaube ich ein
realistischer blick nicht alles wird
sich ändern gerade mit blick auf
strafzölle habe ich noch ein großes
fragezeichen wie weit die beiden sich
davon vom kurs von donald trump lösen
wird aber es gibt zwei riesenchancen mit
joe biden das eine ist dass er ein
überzeugter multilateral ist ist also
internationale organisationen mit ihnen
zu stärken
auch die wto wieder zu stärken da
besteht mit sicherheit eine große chance
und das zweite ist dass joe biden ganz
klar gemacht hat dass er
klimaschutzfragen zum kern einer
handelspolitik machen wird und da eben
die hand zu reichen da eine brücke zu
bauen als europäische union und die usa
voran zu gehen und zu sagen wir
verbinden diese zwei megathemen und
machen dann zum beispiel den klimaschutz
zum kernelement von handelsverträgen
oder schaffen klimazölle an die
klimaschädliche produkte an den
europäischen und amerikanischen grenzen
mit einem preis belegen dass werden
möglichkeiten von denen ich denke da
könnte die eu mit joe biden vorangehen
und damit ein signal an die ganze welt
senden das klimaschädliche technologien
sich nicht mehr lohnen sollen diese hand
gereicht hat gestern auch der
chinesische staatspräsident und für eine
offene weltwirtschaft geworden man
müsste diskriminierende standards regeln
und auch systeme verwerfen sagte er auf
dem davos forum letzte frage mit der
bitte um eine kurze antwort für wie
glaubwürdig halten sie solche appelle
aus peking für globalisierung und
zusammenarbeit
also china hat sich in den letzten
jahren nie an die versprechen gehalten
diese gemacht haben im rahmen der wto
und in anderen verträgen deswegen kann
man da ein großes fragezeichen dran
machen es ist allerdings sehr wichtig
dass die eu hier mit china im dialog
bleibt und darauf drängt dass china sich
zu mehr auf menschenrechten in der
wirtschaftspolitik bekennt und da einen
starken schwerpunkt darauf setzt auch
das hätten wir uns von kanzlerin merkel
im rahmen der letzten verhandlungen mit
china gewünscht der wunsch von katharina
dröge der wirtschaftspolitischen
sprecherin der grünen im deutschen
bundestag ich danke ihnen für das
gespräch und größe nach berlin
vielen dank ihnen auch